let me pull up this story from john
nicosia
source stelter is down to weeks if not
days left at cnn they go on he is
everything that reminds the new owners
of the zucker era they desperately want
to get past
they continue
management is confident stelter is the
one sharing the internal pushback to
fellow media reporters while
simultaneously stirring discontent
within the ranks looks like we've got
some more here he said at 1 49 p.m
to uh uh february 2nd 222 i'm sorry
february 2nd 2022 two sources former cnn
zucker uh former cnn zucker's girlfriend
allison gollust will not be staying on
with the network once dust settles and
then he publishes
on february 20th she resigns so he's
basically saying he was right then brian
stelter may be on the way out at cnn i
bring him up along with this taylor
lauren story because like i mentioned
i'm just going to say it again there is
a big picture of luke owski in the
middle of times square one of the
biggest billboards how is that for
winning and pushing back on the elites
and telling them that we are taking
these spaces to see these people getting
the boot to see their credibility in the
gutter it's a it's a good day
daley wire had a story on that article
and i think your tweet response to this
was in there and i noticed mine was as
well because i got a google alert
there's a part of me i genuinely feel
bad for uh stelter stelter
stealth
delta i genuinely feel bad for him
to some extent
but but he has demonstrated actual
malice he demonstrated malice with that
kid who asked him the question uh
recently at uh yeah the high school kid
the high school kid he was i i feel
terrible he came on the show for an
interview um
i won't remember his name you know puts
on a smiley face oh yeah we really have
to work better on this as the media and
then gives them the cold shoulder when
the cameras aren't running stuff they're
liars but
my analogy was that you know it it's an
actual it comes from real life
experience in our country place my
parents cottage we had most problem and
we put out a bucket of of a bucket with
some bird seed in it and to wait for the
mice to get up they got up they fell in
they didn't get back out
they were all happy until they ran out
of food then they started eating each
other oh lit literally so
this is like mice in a bucket they'll
they'll play with each other when you
know there's enough food to eat and then
when the food starts going short they
literally start eating each other no
honor among scoundrels and it couldn't
happen to a better industry yeah man i
gotta say i agree
we're watching the downward spiral man
yeah independent media is gonna take
over it is taking over the stuff i see
in the background of what's happening
people from these types of organizations
coming to us wanting to go the
independent route this is the
the world is changing
and a lot of these organizations don't
see it quite yet but there are some
individuals in some of these
organizations that do and they're
starting to reach out and
this is something that's gonna i think
accelerate a lot in the next you know
six months to a year especially over the
next two or three years yeah independent
media will take over i definitely it's
inevitable i definitely agree with you
because the the more they try to
suppress the truth the more they promote
the the truth uh tellers but it's even
talent at these organizations
that are starting to realize this and
they're starting to realize they're
restricted and they want it they want to
have a show like tim's in three it's
happening
three in three years
um we're i'm going to be it's going to
be you know
wednesday
it's going to be thursday at 9 00 a.m
and i'm going to be like hey luke that
uh 4 6 is coming out do you want to go
you want to go catch it over at the
local amc and look to be like okay we'll
catch that thursday preview we're going
to show up we're going to walk up to the
counter to get some snow caps and brian
is going to turn around and be like
would you like anything else anything
else with that
he'll be fine he made a lot of money the
one thing is chris probably had no idea
10 years ago when you started rumble
you for the next five years are going to
be
uh number one target because this is
you're starting something which is going
to be the platform
for the independent voices who are being
snuffed out pushed out and censored on
what had hitherto been the free speech
platforms
so are you are you ready
i better be i better be well that's uh i
love what i do i love this space and i
really strongly believe in it so
absolutely did you guys see that smear
piece about florida like the far right
is moving which one oh yeah
i've seen a few of those
smear pieces like every week there's one
i think i just typed in brian stetler
into a brave search and one of the
articles that comes up is from the new
york post talking about how his reliable
sources first of all why would you name
a show like that when you're such a
propagandist but that's why but it's
titled reliable sources on cnn draws
lowest ratings since
2019.
so they're feeling i mean it's 73 000
viewers in the key demographic that's
how many views i get when i post a video
of chickens outside tim that you had
half you had 40 000 people watching an
empty studio for two and a half hours
last week i mean and and and generating
revenue while it happens i mean it's
it's nuts people want to support quality
the people who can't succeed on a
merit-based system yup want to suppress
that quality exactly the people at these
big these big journalist outlets
they have no merit they have no talent
and so they rely on this gigantic
foundation of 100 year old institution
or institutions so that they can climb
they can be let in the front door take
the elevator to the top and then scream
their garbage opinions at the world for
the rest of us that use that have built
up our own followings and done the hard
work over time it's because we've said
things that have been insightful we've
challenged we've we've been brave or
we've just done the hard work and over a
long enough period of time that results
in a following that's merit they could
never earn and they despise us for it
well think about it you know
collectively you guys have more members
on your own subscription stuff than cnn
plus put together
with 300 million dollars of investment
that was horrifying like think about
that
i i i did a live stream with nate brody
another youtube lawyer of the law tube
about the jan six hearings and i'm
pulling up articles published
publications i want to get anyone in
trouble on this but relating to
previous reporting by cnn npr
about issues with machines leaving with
that
cnn had a video from 10 years ago it had
1400 views on it and this is cnn with
they have millions 1400 views and their
stuff now there's a reason why they turn
off comments there's a reason why they
don't let you see the thumbs up well
that was youtube but
it's the reason why youtube did that
don't question this to protect the weak
and and punish the strong
well the the saying uh goes that any
sufficiently unmoderated platform will
become right-wing but the idea is that
the right probably has a tendency
towards meritocracy because the people
who are strong enough to lead end up
doing it their view of it is
the people of twitter at twitter have
said this they need to create a health
the health of the conversation like you
were mentioning earlier
so they view themselves as stewards of
fairness
it doesn't work you can't cut off the
tall grass and tall grass sacrifice
those who do the hard work and then prop
up people who don't and that's what
they've been doing and it doesn't work
it's it's creating all of this all of
these problems i i i would flip the
expression i i appreciate the expression
but i wouldn't say anything left to its
own or you know free speech tends to
turn right wing i would just say that
those who tend to fail on their own
merits
try to restrict the rules so it nothing
changes in the essence except for the
the the overton's window shifts to the
left so what was
center looks like it was right wing but
no
freedom of speech tends to go right-wing
not so much it's that those who don't
succeed with their speech try to
suppress the speech of those who do in i
would say in the last like three four
months you know we've seen a lot of
people on the left perceived left come
to rumble um that you wouldn't typically
have thought would have came
like activists for example susan
sarandon tweeting rumble like what that
actually happened she's she's on the
left i thought right
um so you're starting to see like this
kind of
this free speech
thing happen
on all angles now it's not just
happening with one
defined group but many different groups
well gaming whatever it may be any
category it's it's happening across the
spectrum and it's getting really
aggressive and worse well it's why the
young turks uh you know are now being
critical of independent left creators
the i mean they grew up as being the
book as being the bernie sanders auntie
obama you know voice of the progressive
left that the institutional media wasn't
covering then they transition into trump
hatred and then they transition into
being sort of corporate establishment
media that they themselves used to be
critical of have to rely on donations
from corporate and
big you know billionaire less sugar
daddies on the left and consequently
their their support is shrinking and
shrinking and shrinking because they're
no longer organic or authentic or
independent there's people on the left
that could build a huge uh a independent
market spectrum like tulsi gabbard like
glenn greenwald like aaron mate like max
blumenthal son of city of blumenthal
like the gray zone
if they
continue to do independent information
that's reliable and trustworthy even
though it comes from a left perspective
the thirst and the hunger is for
independent honest authentic information
exactly yeah kyle kalinski and crystal
ball i think are fantastic well there's
there's the the no true scotsman thing
about this is that left-wing voices who
want to succeed they move to rumble but
the second you do that you become right
wing so tulsi gabbard ghost rumble right
wing russell brand goes to rumble right
wing jimmy dore goes rumble right wing
and so jimmy dore is a socialist isn't
he he's
he's the guy who spat on alex jones in
the 2016. we were there me and him were
in the room as it was happening
that's assault brother
it technically was but i mean glenn
greenwald when you call the the the gay
liberal uh who's very critical of
bolsonaro and brazil uh in the guy who
helped break probably more investigative
journalistic stories than any individual
reporter in the last decade you call him
right wing it shows that they they have
a fallback position they called joe fast
company one article saying you know
beware right wing comedy from joe rogan
to the babylon b and it's like what okay
i'll take it i guess look it's just
it becomes a circular definitional veer
away your right wing even if you even if
you're as left as russell brand and
tulsi gabbard you veer your rights and
that's it joe rogan goes on his show and
says universal basic income which is
very very left and not he's right-wing i
mean okay dude his favorite candidate
was between bernie sanders and tulsi
gabbard i mean he's been consistently on
the left so the but i think it's just
self-discrediting like like when you get
to the point where you're calling johnny
depp supporters right wing you have lost
the narrative and you've lost
institutional confidence you are if you
when you're at the point where
commenting on a johnny depp civil case
means you're radicalized you've lost the
plot and that's that's the corporate
press at this point there were people on
our respective communities robert barnes
and i that they didn't they didn't care
for johnny depp because he because of
his anti-trump statements you know and
call for violence statements um
but when it comes to these types of
things that people who are independent
thinkers can see beyond their own biases
and just come to the conclusions based
on the facts and yeah just anyone who
agrees with johnny depp right wing
misogynist even if they happen to be
left-wing women
let that thanks for checking out this
segment from the tim cast irl podcast
but if you want to check out the full
show live tune in monday through friday
at 8 p.m and if you want more special
access content head over to timcast.com
and become a member your membership
helps sustain this company keep our
journalists employed makes this show
happen and you will get access to
exclusive members only segments of the
tim cast irl podcast and there's a
massive library to check out so again go
to timcast.com or tune in monday through
friday at 8 pm we'll see you all there
you